saturday night live is back this weekend
after a month-long hiatus and
a little birdie told me that the world
has given them a lot to talk about
oh stop it i can't stop it's too good
get your pearls and chucks ready
everybody because you know
maya rudolph is gonna bring it i cannot
wait for this and neither can
good friend and snl alone kristen wiig
i'm just gonna play a quick song on my
phone
[Music]
first of all she sounds exactly like her
thank you
good evening thank you everybody she's a
genius i could watch her do
her all day it's amazing i don't know
that i nailed it but i definitely tried
to make her
fun we're not going to stand here and
gloat wow
i just want to do her proud good job
no pressure snl riders are still hard at
work but we expect maya rudolph will
make her first appearance as now vice
president kamala harris this weekend
john krasinski hosts for the first time
megan fox's man machine gun kelly is the
musical guest
and boy is there a lot to cover i can't
even imagine how you guys would put
it all in an episode i don't know i mean
we're gonna do as much as
we can we have a lot to celebrate you
know i think that cold open should just
start with cooling the game you know
what i'm saying
a lot of it will probably come out of
update you know as far as like firing
off what the biggest stories have been
keenan's pulling double duty this season
he's got a new show keenan coming out
next month on
nbc in addition to snl this is his
record
18th season as a cast member what is
being the longest
like tenured uh person on that show what
does that mean to you
it's an incredible you know badge of
honor that i wear really proudly